bonjour bonjour à toutes et à tous sens
public votre nouveau rendez vous sur
public sénat 90 minutes de débat
d'actualité et de réflexion notre
objectif c'est donner du sens donner de
la profondeur à l'actualité avec trois
temps dans cette émission un débat
d'actualité d'abord pour commencer on
vous proposera tous les jours un débat
d'actualité aujourd'hui on analyse le
bilan du beauvau de la sécurité sur les
terres électorales de xavier bertrand et
marine le pen le président de la
république a annoncé des postes de
l'argent mais aussi plus de contrôles
pour l'institution policière deuxième
temps de ce sens public la rubrique les
électeurs ont la parole vous pouvez
d'ailleurs d'ores et déjà réagir sur les
espaces sociaux avec le mot diez le
hashtag sens public évidemment vous
pouvez réagir notamment sur le thème du
jour la hausse du prix de l'essence plus
de 2 euros pour le sans plomb 95 dans
certaines stations-service réaction et
surtout explications tout à l'heure et
puis dans un troisième temps notre
second débat débat exploratoire débat
prospectif consacrée aujourd'hui au
mépris cette maladie de la société
française cette maladie qui stratifie
notre société reste à ta place c'est le
titre d'un livre passionnant c'est aussi
la phrase qu'on a entendu les nicolas
sarkozy anne hidalgo bernard tapie ou
eric dupond moretti ont trouvé un motor
mais combien d'autres sont restés au
bord de la route on y reviendra un peu
avant 19 heures voilà pour les titres
mais d'abord les annonces des manuels
macron à roubaix pour boucler huit mois
de discussions calmer la colère
policière et renouer la confiance
parfois distendu parfois perdus entre
les français et leurs forces de l'ordre
quand un caennais
l'elysée avait par les annonces
substantielle et de changements radicaux
la promesse était au rendez vous avec
tout d'abord une nouvelle rallonge
financière de 500 millions d'euros qui
vient s'ajouter à une hausse du budget
de 900 millions d'euros déjà prévus
c'est sans précédent
95 %
95 % de ces mesures qui ressorte du
beauvau sont pour du matériel de
l'investissement les conditions de
travail le budget de la police qui doit
faire l'objet prochainement d'une grande
loi de programmation prévue en conseil
des ministres début 2022 dans le même
temps le chef de l'état a annoncé une
simplification qu'il veut drastique de
la conduite des enquêtes en passant
davantage par les amendes forfaitaires
et la possibilité de porter plainte en
ligne enfin une autre annonce
structurelles un nouveau schéma du
maintien de l'ordre une intervention du
chef de l'état qu'il a voulu équilibrer
avec quelques annonces en faveur de
davantage de contrôle de la profession
comme avec la publication des rapports
de l'igpn ou encore une nouvelle
instance de contrôle parlementaire des
forces de l'ordre voilà pourquoi aussi
je proposerai au président deux chambres
parlementaires que sur le modèle de la
délégation parlementaire au
renseignement soit créé une instance de
contrôle parlementaire des forces de
l'ordre qui pourra procéder à
l'évaluation de leurs actions à roubaix
emmanuel macron ainsi multiplié les
annonces sur ce sujet hautement
régaliens un des enjeux de la campagne
présidentielle
le bo vous de la sécurité pour en
débattre j'accueille cas michel bonjour
vous êtes porte parole du ministère de
l'intérieur bienvenus david le bar
bonjour je vous êtes secrétaire générale
du syndicat des commissaires scpn unsa
jérôme durain dont j'ai amené à vous
aussi sénateur socialiste de saône et
loire vous avez participé à ces tables
rondes du bo de la sécurité en
visioconférence avec nous sarah massoud
qui est secrétaire national du syndicat
de la magistrature bonjour et bienvenue
à vous aussi et lætitia cru pas que
j'accueille sur ce plateau pour voilà sa
première participer à l'émission tout
comme matthieu croissandeau qui étaient
là hier vous avez ma compagne et pendant
toute l'émission dans le rôle
d'éditorialiste politique bienvenue
laetitia c'est du bonheur de vous
retrouver sur un plateau de télé on a eu
quelques années de médias le magazine
ensemble ça rappelle des des souvenirs
si j'essaye de résumer le mais alors
c'est c'est toujours un exercice
périlleux mais si moi je le résume en
deux mots le discours les annonces de
d'emmanuel macron jeudi des moyens et un
contrôle de l'institution policière est
ce que vous dites que c'est équilibré
david howarth et est ce que vous vous
faites ce résumé j'allais j'allais vous
répondre que je ne ferais pas ce résumé
voilà moi je résumerais ci doit je dois
le faire en deux points sur ce qui est
bon pour le citoyen et ce qui est bon
pour le policier est ce qui va permettre
de faire la police de 2030 et dans ce
discours là mais j'imagine qu'on n'en
débattra il ya énormément d'ambition il
ya énormément de décision on verra
évidemment après selon les actes et ce
qui sera fait ou ce qui sera pas fait
parce que il ya beaucoup de choses dans
ce discours j'ai trouvé que ce discours
était très équilibré et avait pour une
fois et politiquement je n'ai pas
souvent entendu le mérite de nous
projeter en 2030
2010-2030 week de milan jérôme durain
huit mois de travail huit tables rondes
est ce que le résultat est à la hauteur
pour vous qui avez vraiment vu les
tiraillements les propositions les
bonnes idées moins bonnes qui ont pu
émerger c'est un discours qui est à la
hauteur du beauvau et qui est
caractérisée ou entachées des mêmes
difficultés que nous a dit le boulot il
ya beaucoup de citoyens beaucoup
d'expérience
étrangers réception policière ça a été
quand même beaucoup en vase clos alors
je pense que ce discours il fera plaisir
dans les gendarmeries dans les
commissariats et c'est une bonne chose
oui c'est d'ailleurs c'est le premier
son de cloche de parce qu'il faut
répondre aux besoins des policiers mais
on attend du président de la république
à la fin d'un quinquennat et juste avant
la campagne une autre vision de la
sécurité locale et moyens il a dit
d'ailleurs un président 95% ce sont des
moyens mais quid de la doctrine d'emploi
par exemple en s'agissant du maintien de
l'ordre
quid du calendrier de ce discours
puisque finalement il vient nous
expliquer à la fin du quinquennat ce
qu'il aurait fallu faire pendant sa la
formation l'information ça va pas mais
c'est un des cinq ministres d'intérieur
qui a réduit la formation en matant faut
la rétablir et puis
surtout sur le contrôle c'est très peu
ambitieux on y reviendra j'imagine
spécifiquement et c'est très peu
ambitieux
parlementaire d'où je parle
politiquement le principal sujet c'était
renouer la confiance entre les citoyens
et les forces de l'ordre et je pense que
s'agissant du discours on n'y est pas
encore sa relation votre sentiment
global pour commencer et puis ensuite
qu'à michetz vous donnera la parole
comme ça vous aurez eu les trois sons de
cloche
ou un peu l'intervenant précédent
extrêmement déçu on nous parle de
grandes réformes de radicalité de
changement de paradigme on est quand
même très très en-deça que ce soit
d'ailleurs pour l'institution judiciaire
pour l'institution policière ou pour la
population on voit que va y avoir un
budget qui va être en très nette
augmentation ça c'est plutôt un bien
j'ai envie de vous dire ça serait bien
que ça sera le cas pour d'autres
services publics après on va voir
comment ces égrainé si c'est gris et
seulement pour augmenter le nombre de
policiers dans la rue c'est faire fi
quand même du fait que ce n'est pas
parce qu'il ya plus d'agents de bleu à
seat est interpellé par cette
utilisation du terme après la république
du bleu c'est assez méprisant à l'égard
des policiers m'ont bref a pas vraiment
eu gain de cause il n'a pas cette fois
c'est en ça on sait de quoi il parle
quand il dit ça tout simplement ça parle
aux français oui mais c'est quand même
un terme à ses côtés je trouve ça tout
ça pas très patrie juste à l'endroit à
l'endroit de nos collègues policiers
mais tout ça pour vous dire que c'est
parce qu'on aime
ça vous choque pas d'avis notamment
parce que vous savez c'est comme flic
faut assumer ce qu'on est il n'y a pas
d' insulte quand on dit flick ou bleu
simplement ça veut dire visibilité c'est
pour ça que le ministre en poils mots
bleus c'est pour que ça se voit et que
les français soient rassurés demande
pardon je vous est interrompue cette
arme à sion 2 c est elle qui
contrairement à ce qu'il vient de dire
et sur le plateau c'est que ça fait
maintenant trente ans il ya quand même
de nombreuses études notamment anglo
saxonnes c'est pas parce qu'il ya plus
de bleu dans la rue dans l'espace public
sur la voie publique qu' il n'y a pas
plus de passage à l'acte c'est pas plus
protecteur pour les citoyens et c'est
pas plus dissuasif c'est pas parce que
il ya plus de policiers dans une rue que
vous n'avez pas vous allez avoir moins
d'agressions one voice et faut donc
d'exercer faire fi des analyses
sociologiques d'ailleurs les sociologues
et était absent de ce beau but de la
sécurité donc du coup assez déçu et puis
on attend de voir aussi comment sera
égrainé tous eu tout ce budget est en
termes de formation de sociologie
policière de métier les polices des
liens aussi entre police et population
sur le contrôle des policiers alain pour
le coup on est très très en deçà de ce
qu'on peut attendre nos institutions
d'édition vous vous serez avec nous
pendant tout le débat évidemment donc
vous aurez l'occasion de prendre la
parole à de nombreuses reprises kamyshev
première réponse peut-être sur ce ce
constat qu'ils imaginent vous fait
tiquer c'est pas parce qu'il ya plus de
policiers qui a moins de cas moins de
délinquance complètement moi ce que j'ai
trouvé au rendez vous dans ce discours
et dans toutes les tables rondes que
j'ai le plaisir d'animer donc j'ai été
aux premières chef de de toutes ces
discussions c'est qu'il y avait une
promesse c'était de tenir compte des
évolutions récentes de la société de
l'augmentation de la violence du
terrorisme qui est toujours présent des
vagues migratoires des évolutions
numériques aussi de la société avec tous
les débats sur les captation d'image par
exemple de prendre tous ces éléments de
la société qui avait changé et d'en
parler ensemble est d'arriver à partager
quelque chose tous ensemble quelles que
soient les bords politiques et c'est
pour ça qu'il y avait des telus des élus
de terrain des parlementaires quelles
que soient les syndicats et on sait que
dans notre maison police il ya des
syndicats plus gros plus progressiste
que d'autres et il y avait aussi des
personnes qui n'avaient peut-être jamais
franchi les portes de des ministères ou
très rarement la présidente de la cnil
hier qui a pu s'exprimer le garde des
sceaux qui a été une réunion présent
avec l'ensemble des syndicats et tout ça
c'était des signes qu'on avait envie de
partager quelque chose ensemble un
constat sociétal pour trouver des socios
des solutions ensemble et les annonces y
en a eu quand même beaucoup joué la plus
importante pour vous pour moi la plus
importante c'est celle qui a déjà été
évoqué c'est un doublement des policiers
sur le terrain pourquoi ça veut dire que
on se met vraiment au service de la
population qu'on est accessible à la
population qu'on peut aller parler aux
policiers qu on le voit dans la rue
quand on en a besoin comme quand on en a
moins besoin il ya ce sentiment aussi de
sécurité qui va pouvoir
redevenir vraiment centrale et puis ça
veut dire pour nous policiers et
gendarmes une réforme énorme en fait de
notre organisation ça veut dire
peut-être au moins deux policiers de
gendarmes dans les états-majors
peut-être moins deux comptes rendus
statistiques c'est aussi une autre
manière de faire de la police qui va
être nécessaire avec cette évolution de
plus de policiers sur le terrain et
aussi plus d'administratif pour des
fonctions administratives plus de
personnel scientifique pour faire des
constatations scientifiques on pourrait
dire que c'est basique au banik mais ça
va en jantes rennais d'airé formation
des réformes structurelles importantes
qu'est ce que vous répondez à sarah
massoud sur le set cette affirmation se
bat aussi à plus de policiers qu'il ya
moins de délinquance il ya deux aspects
il ya les réalités statistiques et puis
elle sentiment d'insécurité on a
suffisamment parlé de sentiment
d'insécurité dans la société française
pour être en mesure de dire quand on
voit des policiers contrairement à ceux
qui dénigrent la police pour la grande
majorité des citoyens avoir accès à la
police de proximité sur le terrain que
ce soit dans des commissariats dans des
accueils dans la rue c'est un plus donc
voilà je vous donnais à chelsea 1 68%
des français ont confiance dans la
police 52 % des jeunes sa baisse de
moins de 10% de 10% en un an - 10% en
avant oui comme et c'est vrai pour une
bonne partie de la population mais il ya
quand même une petite fracture avec les
jeunes sur laquelle il va il faut
travailler mais c'est aussi une occasion
de mettre plus de policiers sur le
terrain et être sur le terrain c'est pas
forcément faire durer près si vous savez
ce qu'on ce qu'on paye entre guillemets
depuis quelques années là c'est une
utilisation très intensive de la police
en maintien de l'ordre parce qu'il ya
une période de contestation sociale très
forte pour différentes causes pourra pas
tout lister et qui fait qu'on ait vu à
juste titre comme une police employés
sur un volet répressif et on a un peu
oublié d'autres missions qui sont les
nôtres qui sont notamment tout ce qui
est prévention secours assistance etc on
a un déficit de communication et dans le
discours que j'ai entendu aujourd'hui
l'intention c'est de se rapprocher de la
population avec des actes type quand on
simplifie la procédure caisse à qui on
va s'adresser à des citoyens acquis
aujourd'hui on dit la plainte n'est pas
traitée on est en retard et demain si on
peut traiter plus vite qui va se
plaindre de ça je crois que c'est un
plus pour tout le monde si on y arrive
il y aussi un tour - un tournant de la
numérisation qui a été évoqué on sait
que nos services sont en retard en
termes de digitalisation de systèmes
d'information et là les choses sont très
claires c'est ambitieux mais c'est ce
qu'on demande aux politiques d'être
ambitieux pour les administrations qui
doivent ensuite travaillé et voilà une
plainte en ligne à partir de 2023 c'est
un beau projet qu'on met sur la table
jérôme durand
emmanuel macron ce matin c'était le
premier flic de france il a dit dans son
discours vous avez demandé mon dans le
beau vaut d'ailleurs vous l'avez dit les
gendarmes ont exprimé c'est pas son
boulot darmanin peut faire ça mais c'est
pas son boulot à emmanuel macron sais
quelle vision on a de la sécurité dans
ce pays pas seulement par les moyens les
crédits vous disiez 62% des français
apprécient la police ont confiance et
52% heureusement et on est tous derrière
les policiers et les gendarmes mais ce
que vous ne dites pas c'est que ça un
peu des crues
surtout chez les jeunes surtout chez les
jeunes mais globalement dans la
population même si c'est une des
institutions les plus appréciés les plus
respectés on l'a dit à juste raison saab
et c'est donc cette question de la
confiance
dans l'institution policière dans la
gendarmerie elle n'est pas traitée
simplement en écoutant les policiers
indiens dégâts 3 vous avez besoin je
vais vous le donnez donc si j'ai entendu
c'est un peu manque de souffle quoi
manque de sa vendeuse ou ça manque de
vision et puis ça arrive bien tard
coincé alors justement est-ce que ça
arrive pas un peu tard laëtitia ne suis
pas pour la campagne mais par rapport au
quinquennat on met du sien c'est ce que
vous avez raison c'était pour me et flic
de france parce qu'il s'adresse
essentiellement aux français je pense
que monsieur vous avez bien compris le
public que vise emmanuel macron et c'est
pas les flics les flics c'est darmanin
qui s'en occupe et c'est pour ça qu'on
est allé le chercher trop tard il me
semble aussi parce que évidemment que
ces mesures il semble t'il un satisfont
la majorité des forces de police et de
gendarmerie mais quid de leurs
applications thomas c'est à dire que là
on a bien compris que de toute façon ce
serait après l'élection présidentielle
quelques mesures vont passer par voie
réglementaire mais si emmanuel macron se
présente si il tapait beaucoup de si si
il n'est pas élu et bien hop c'est tout
tout tout ces mesures bobos sont
oubliées passe à la trappe et pourquoi
on a perdu c'est aussi une façon de
construire un pont sur un second
quinquennat bien c'est as oui mais enfin
c'est un pari je ne sais pas celui qui
aujourd'hui à le résultat perçu 1022 je
vois là je m'engage c'est un échec et
j'ai des chèques voilà donc on a bien
compris que c'était aussi un déplacement
de campagne et c'est pour ça que c'est
emmanuel macron qui prend 7,7
communication en charge il l'avait fait
déjà à montpellier en avril il dit
exactement la même chose moi mon
objectif c'est convives tous dans la
dans un milieu paisible donc voilà on a
on a tous en h ausse son champ lexical
on à ses objectifs maintenant encore une
fois à partir de quand les français
puisque c'est à eux que le chef de
l'état s'adresse vont pouvoir voir sur
le terrain constater des avancées dans
leur vie quotidien alors effectivement
la question du calendrier est ce que ça
arrive trop tard camichel moi ce que je
vois c'est que depuis wettre
ressentiment une mince avance ce que je
vois c'est depuis quatre ans maintenant
on a vécu un centre de crise qu'il a
fallu absorber on a on continue à avoir
la crise du terrorisme qui est présente
avec des moyens le président de la
république l'a rappelé la crise
migratoire la crise sanitaire qui a fait
que nous les policiers les gendarmes de
terrain on était extrêmement occupés sur
toutes ces questions et donc c'est
difficile j'imagine de réformer un pays
dans ces conditions à vitesse grand v là
moi je trouve au contraire que le
calendrier fixé du point de vue de
l'administration et ambitieux avec des
délais très courts si on l'a ressenti
par mois pardon quelles mesures
pourraient être ressentis voilà
rapidement par les français et on
referme la politique avant la
présidentielle
par exemple sur le terrain des rodéos
urbains ou de la lutte contre les
stupéfiants le démantèlement d'un
certain nombre de points de deal amendes
forfaitaires délictuelle qui est une
amende immédiate il y en a eu plus de
55000 qui ont été délivrées en six mois
de temps et avant c'était du procès
verbal des procédures qui n'était pas
réalisé un temps extrêmement important
pour les enquêteurs ça c'est des choses
concrètes qui font changer les choses
qui
font s'estomper un certain nombre de
points de deal qui font que des
délinquants sont verbalisés
immédiatement et qu'on les touche au
portefeuille pour reprendre l'expression
du président de la république ça c'est
des choses concrètes et qui de ce qui a
été annoncé aujourd'hui vont être
amplifiées dans l'est dans les jours et
les mois
sûrement écrans de contrôle je vois
sarah massoud qui fait des grands gestes
et qui qui fait non de la tête alors il
faut qu'on vous entende qui est pourquoi
ça vous fait réagir
deux choses je pense qu'il ya eu un pas
positif dans le discours des ménages
macron c'était de dire qu'il faut
absolument redonner du corps
investigations via assez suffisamment
d'enquêteurs aujourd'hui les policiers
ont fui lé métier d'enquêteur vous savez
les flics un peu à l'ancienne
véritablement qui enquête à charge et à
décharge qui prennent un peu le temps
que les enquêtes préliminaires sur les
affaires un coup un peu plus graves et
bien aujourd'hui il faut redonner un peu
cette possibilité d'être au pjd
officiers de police judiciaire et de
refaire de l'enquète parce que les freak
les policiers les bleus comme utiliser
l'expression de votre collègue et bien
vous tombe sur la voie publique
patrouiller la politique du chili parce
qu'aujourd'hui enquêter c'est beaucoup
c'est beaucoup de temps beaucoup
pression qui ne sont pas donné et c'est
le coeur de métier des policiers donc
aujourd'hui on nous dit oui va y avoir
le doublement des policiers en disant il
sur la voie publique c'est pas sur la
voie publique de la tête et policiers
les policiers ils doivent être pour
l'écoutent des différentes parties pas
seulement des victimes mais aussi des
mises en cause des avocats des témoins
mener des enquêtes je vais vous dire
quelque chose moi gt gt au parquet de
paris pendant très longtemps et j'ai été
aussi juge d'instruction et les
policiers me disais mais madame massoud
moi j'en peux plus j'ai pas le moyen de
mener des enquêtes et puis j'ai constaté
aussi au fur et à mesure des années dans
les groupes que ce soit la pj la police
judiciaire où les sûretés c'est à dire
le niveau un peu supérieur des
commissariats qui font des enquêtes un
tout petit peu plus poussé y'a plus
procéduriers cesser ces policiers qui
ont fait le même nombre d'études que des
magistrats qui sont des freins
spécialise la procédure pénale défunt
spéciale du droit pénal et tout ça et
bien ces policiers qui montrent les
enquêtes qui savent aggloméré
conseillère book qui connaissent les
droits des avocats des uns et des autres
construire une procédure contre lui à
des investigations et la pluie des
procédures et donnait on vous entendu
merci pardon nous intéresse merci ça
ramasse ou deux c'est vrai david le voir
s'il ya plus de procédurier on est sur
un point haut là mais c'est aussi
intéressant un débat comme celui-là
d'entrer dans les détails vous le savez
très franc on a une crise des métiers de
l'investigation ouais mais qui a des
causes qu'est ce que c'est la crise des
métiers d'investigation je suis un
produit de l'investigation c'est que
j'ai démarré ma carrière je vais faire
simple on pouvait faire une procédure
sur du papier libre c'est à dire que
l'enquêteur de l'époque était capable de
faire une procédure sur papier libre
d'aller en urgence en perquisition chez
quelqu'un vous savez rédiger des pv à la
main aujourd'hui même quelqu'un qui a un
niveau de diplôme incroyable ne pourra
plus jamais faire une procédure sur
papier libre pourquoi non pas que c'est
interdit mais parce que c'est tellement
complexe elle s'est tellement alourdi
que vous êtes sûr de faire une faute de
procédure majeure même même pas
accessoire majeur je pèse mes mots
qu'est ce qui manque ça vend pas
seulement deux policiers d'investigation
dans une crise de l'investigation qu'il
faut régler le président a annoncé que
demain dans le futur les gardiens de la
paix en école serait au pgi en sortant
d'école bien évidemment tout ça doit se
construire mais qu'est ce qui manque
pour une police efficace j'ai vu les
déclarations qui ont été faites ici et
là à marseille il manque le tube de la
chaîne pénale c'est à dire le tube de la
justice qui elle-même soit en mesure
d'absorber moi je veux bien qu'on dise
qui a passé d'enquêteurs mais en france
on a deux à trois fois moins de
magistrats par rapport à l'allemagne
l'angleterre j'aimerais entendre les
magistrats et madame massoud dire on
manque de magistrats on manque de
greffiers on a aussi besoin d'absorber
la capacité procédurales de la police
pour ensuite pouvoir traiter mieux le
délinquant et donc mieux répondre aux
victimes et c'est là où j'ai aussi
apprécié le discours du président de la
république et aussi les points de
discordance c'est qu'il a abordé la
chaîne pénale et ça j'ai trouvé ça à la
fois audacieux et en même temps
calendrier très court parce que les
réformes annoncées là par contre je suis
circonspect ça doit aller très vite ça
va nécessiter beaucoup de travail et
pour moitié a annoncé une augmentation
du budget de la justice qui est
normalement
voilà qui doit normalement avoir des
moyens plus supplémentaires pour traiter
tous que toutes les affaires que vous
amener à la police mais à la justice
cette annonce là je n'ai entendu comme
vous je suis
j'ai entendu la question c'est
aujourd'hui quand on annonce un chantier
de simplification de la procédure pénale
par exemple simplifié les cadres
denquête si j'ai bien compris on va
fusionner les enquêtes préliminaires
l'enquêté de flagrance on va donner les
moyens aux policiers d'avoir une
capacité procédurales augmenter puisque
si on fait plus simple on va plus vite
est-ce que face à nous on n'est pas les
uns contre les autres parce que en tout
cas dans la chaîne pénale il y aura
est-ce que ça suive l'acceptation du
sujet ou est ce qu'on aura réticences
moi pour vous dire des choses j'ai
accepté plusieurs fois de participer à
des commissions j'ai plus vu des
réticences dans ma vie que de gens en
capacité de simplement pas que ça
devienne un ping pong entre le policier
la magistrate mais je vous donne la
parole saravah soul forcément qu'est ce
que vous répondez à david de bars
d'avoir dit que il manquait il manquait
des effectifs à la magistrature c'est
flagrant un ancien garde des sceaux
disait qu'on était qu'on était des
clochards vous savez aujourd'hui les
recrutements à eux mêmes sont quasiment
en deçà il ya quelques années donc pour
former un juge et pour vraiment un
greffier faut plusieurs années donc on
est tellement de sa de ce qu'il faudrait
donc c'est pour ça que à mon sens c'est
véritablement des ambitions de grande
envergure qu'il faudrait aujourd'hui la
la magistrature n'est pas en capacité
d'absorber
l'ensemble des enquêtes qui lui sont
soumises que c'est à dire d enquête de
flagrance des enquêtes préliminaires moi
je vous parle d instruction des grosses
affaires celle qui intéresse aussi la
criminalité organisée les affaires les
plus lourdes donc aujourd'hui il faut
mais un recrutement massif de magistrats
alors après avoue d'interroger les miz
et de la justice qui n'est pas du tout
dans cette danse est prospective là il
est so des sucres raguy donc du coup oui
c'est vrai on a eu quelques centaines de
contractuels et décontractée pour faire
quoi pour faire de la petite procédure
pas du tout ce dont on parle aujourd'hui
donc je suis tout à fait d'accord
augmentons moyens de la justice et pas
seulement 8% c'est véritablement peanuts
par rapport à nous et à nos collègues
européens pour pouvoir absorber absorber
ça et puis jean rose merci restez avec
nous restez avec nous ça va parce que
c'est toujours un peu plus compliqué
quand il ya un invité qui est en duplex
en visioconférence mais merci
d'intervenir en tout cas parce que je
voudrais qu'on prenne du temps pour
faire un focus sur une autre mesure très
commentée évidemment la création de
d'une instance de contrôle sur le modèle
de la délégation parlementaire au
renseignement alors j'avoue que c'était
un peu elliptique pour moi on va voir
quelle forme ça pourrait prendre avec
vous steve jourdain bonjour
manuel mâcon qui souhaite donc s'en
remettre au parlement oui les policiers
que l'exécutif ont alors un peu compris
un voeu choyé choyés mais pas seulement
il souhaite donc aussi mieux contrôler
les forces de l'ordre dans l'exercice de
leurs missions emmanuel macron propose
de créer donc une instance de contrôle
parlementaire en bref des parlementaires
qui serait donc chargé d'évaluer
l'action des forces de l'ordre pas de
précision encore sur les modalités tout
est encore extrêmement floue mais le
mécanisme fait un peu penser à ce qui
existe déjà en matière de renseignement
il existe en effet une délégation
parlementaire au renseignement qui est
composée de quatre députés et de quatre
sénateurs le problème est bien c'est que
les travaux de cette délégation sont
protégés par le secret défense ils ne
sont donc par définition ne m'a pas
accessible au grand public en matière de
transparence le gouvernement peut donc
faire beaucoup beaucoup mieux en tout
cas c'est ce qu'en pense la sénatrice
écologiste sophie calle polian écoutez
là ce qu'on entend poindre c'est à dire
une commission parlementaire me semble
pas du tout pas du tout au niveau parce
que ce dont on a besoin entre autres
c'est de transparence et je ne crois pas
qu'une commission parlementaire du même
type que celles qui travaillent sur le
renseignement qui se caractérise
vraiment pas du tout par les questions
de transparence soit le modèle à suivre
sophie taille et poignant qui propose
que cette nouvelle institution de
contrôle des policiers soient placés
thomas entre les mains de la défenseure
des droits de l'homme objectif
l'indépendance de l'institution
transparence de son travail alors sur la
forme maintenant que quelle forme ça
pourrait prendre à s'en plaint pas
simple pour le gouvernement notamment
quand vous avez bien un sénat qui n'est
pas de votre bord politique pour créer
une telle délégation parlementaire il
faut en effet l'accord des deux
assemblées assemblée nationale sénat est
ici à la haute assemblée on n'est pas
très enthousiaste à cette idée d'
emmanuel macron on considère que le
travail de contrôle des forces de
l'ordre a déjà effectué en pratique il
s'exerce par l'intermédiaire de la
commission des lois que vous connaissez
bien jérôme durain aucun intérêt donc à
créer selon les sénateurs une nouvelle
délégation à nouveau comité théodule qui
n'auraient en pratique aucune
prérogative si l'exécutif souhaite quand
même un créé une telle délégation eh
bien il faudrait passer par benoît et à
quelques mois maintenant de la
présidentielle pas certain que la droite
ici au sénat soit encline à faire un
cadeau emmanuel macron merci steve steve
jourdain donc les chroniques de la
rédaction tous les jours dans cette
émission une chronique à zoom très
factuelle de la rédaction dans chacun de
nos
débat évidemment je me tourne vers vous
jérôme durain est-ce que vous la voulez
7 je vais être un peu triviale cette
patate chaude non non non le cas on
pourrait se dire c'est bien le parlement
reprend un peu de pouvoir dans la sphère
les deux questions les deux termes qui
reviennent systématiquement quand on
parle du contrôle
c'est indépendance et transparence je
rappelle que la défenseur des droits a
aussi une vocation à s'occuper des
questions de déontologie
de police
trop près ou trop loin trop pressée igpn
et gênes les inspections générales
l'agent de la vie nationale et la police
nationale elles sont trop près parce
qu'elle ne présente pas les garanties
d'indépendance et on a cru comprendre
que ça pouvait bouger ce côté-là bon ça
bougera pas ça reste sous l'autorité du
ministre délit caractères généraux rien
à attendre de ce côté-là trop loin le
parlement est donc si on a besoin de
créer une commission d enquête ont fait
un la sphère benalla il me semble que
c'est venu un peu comme ça donc on n'a
pas besoin de parlement n'a pas besoin
que l'exécutif lui demande de s'occuper
du contrôle mais on est trop loin on va
pas aller s'occuper d'un bras arraché
ici d'une suspicion de dérapage ailleurs
et alors qu'est ce que vous espériez
puisque vous avez participé à ces à ses
tableaux qu'est-ce que vous demandiez en
termes de contrôle moi il me semble que
que le bon modèle et c'est d'ailleurs
quelqu'un qu'on a auditionné c'était lie
aux piscines line dépendantes office
pour of fort police quand tu essaies de
l'organisme britannique qui s'occupe du
contrôle qui est indépendant et qui
permet de mettre tous à distance et il
faut donc ce ne sont pas des policiers
qui sont en progression et il faut dire
que les policiers ils font bien leur
ménage 20 globalement il ya 95 97 98 99
% de policiers et de gendarmes qui se
comporte très bien il ya quelques cas
qui demandent cette indépendance est ses
transparences et ça aurait été une
réponse très forte elle n'est pas venue
et peut-être qu'il faut lire d'ailleurs
le coup le discours d' emmanuel macron
moins
à l'aune de ce qu'il y a deux dents
parce que finalement j'ai plutôt a si
mal mais ce qui pose problème c'est tout
ce qu'il n'ya pas notamment sur le
contrôle est ce que c'est une opposition
une résistance du milieu policier et du
milieu de la gendarmerie pour ne pas
avoir cette instance de contrôle a été
le débat ça a été le débat le plus vif
il ya eu deux débats très vifs la table
ronde avec la justice avec eric
dupond-moretti ça ou ça frictionner un
peu et puis dans tout le monde à tout le
monde mais la plupart des policiers se
comportent très très bien mais dans les
débats on a eu aussi sur les inspections
générales des choses un petit peu vivre
pour qu on sent qu'il ya que ça renâcle
banon mais un policier sur ce plateau
donc comment vous réagissez emmanuel
macron je vais le site et quand il ya
des fautes elles doivent être
sanctionnés quand on aime nos forces de
l'ordre on ne leur passe pas tout mais
j'espère que je ne vais pas surprendre
je valide tout ça et je ne suis pas moi
en tant que commissaire de police et en
tant que policier opposé à toute notion
de contrôle faut juste remettre un petit
peu en perspective de trois points
l'igpn a deux façons de travailler sur
son mode banquette il ya le volet
judiciaire il faut évacuer ce pont là il
est fait il est lé dirigé par la justice
une enquête judiciaire c'est soit un
procureur soit un juge d'instruction ils
contrôlent l'anc est donc le contrôle et
déjà fait par une autorité qui est
l'autorité judiciaire dont on parle du
volet administratif sanctions
disciplinaires moi j'ai pris des
positions anti du syndicat des
commissaires de la police nationale s'il
devait y avoir une autorité une forme de
chat potage ou du effectivement d'une
mise à distance mais personne ne
s'oppose à ça il faut juste respecter de
trois règles d'anonymat pour ceux qui
sont cités dans les dossiers il faut
juste rappeler qu'ils gpn je crois pour
le ministère l'intérieur pour la police
on n'a pas loin de 50 % des sanctions
toutes fonctions publiques confondues
s'y reprendre à cinq millions de
fonctionnaires et le contentieux
disciplinaire police nationale c'est 50%
d'édition donc on est contrôlé il faut
pas laisser passer cette petite musique
mais s'il y avait un gage à donner src
faire plus écoutez moi le j'entends de
débats
la commission parlementaire n'est pas
soumise au secret pour l'activité igpn
elle l'est pour le renseignement parce
que la matière est soumise au secret moi
je ne voyais aucune raison qu'une
délégation soumises au secret je ne vois
pas d'opposition à ce que les
parlementaires la craie maintenant
politiquement on verra ce que ça donne
j'essayais faut pas oublier d'où est
partie ce bobo de la sécurité c'est
quand même suite à la ferme et clair ce
producteur de musique avait été arrêté
de façon musclée et tabassé par des
policiers et donc ça
la population il ya eu des
manifestations après dans le sillage
bien sûr des états unis blacklight
sommateurs mais quand même il y avait
sept ce bruit et cette contestation qui
montait de la rue et ce bourreau de la
sécurité a été organisée pour répondre
et pour rassurer les français et
rétablir effectivement cela de confiance
il faut pas oublier ça donc c'est vrai
qu'à l'arrivée quand on à l'instance de
contrôle qui est une simple pardon voilà
l'information parlementaire qui serait
là pour contrôler mais vous l'avez dit
beaucoup trop loin bon on se dit que
finalement on a davantage entendu la
police que les manifestants bon on va
écouter marine le pen puis ensuite vous
pourrez centraliser vos réponses et vos
et et vos arguments marine le pen qui
était ce matin sur cette question de de
la nouvelle instance de contrôle était
ce matin sur europe 1 on écoute chaque
fois qu'il va sur le terrain de la
sécurité c'est pour taper sur la tête
des policiers moi j'aimerais bien qu'ils
se mettent un peu à taper sur la tête
des délinquants et des criminels ça
pourrait être une forme de nouveautés
c'est surtout beaucoup plus efficace
pour lutter contre l'insécurité donc il
a vraiment un billet le président qui
est un biais de de suspicion à l'égard
de la police nationale d'à priori
négatifs à l'égard de la police
nationale il l'a démontré à plusieurs
reprises il a parlé lui-même comme
président de la république des violences
policières je ne dis pas que il n'y a
pas quelques individus parfois avec très
contrôlée d'ailleurs déjà action
extrêmement combler ses positions c'est
probablement le corps le plus contrôlé
camille 16 comment voyager c'est
peut-être d'abord aux propos de marine
le pen à moi je réagis pas aux propos
politique je suis fonctionnaire et je
suis apolitique non de ce qui était
important pour nous les policiers les
gendarmes c'était de dire que c'était
aux policiers aux gendarmes de contrôler
leur profession on veut pas externaliser
donner à d'autres notes patate chaude
pour reprendre
on a vraiment on a vraiment besoin que
le contrôle interne dans les forces de
police et de gendarmerie soient partout
sa part du gradé qui est dans les
brigades ça passe par le commissaire
l'officier de gendarmerie et on veut pas
finalement déléguer à d'autres ce
travail qu'est ce que vous répondez à la
critique qui a été exprimé trop trop
trop près d'un côté trop loin de l'autre
nous on voulait le garder ce pouvoir de
contrôle qui doit être partout et c'est
notre fierté d'être contrôlés et c'est
notre fierté de dire que à 99% les
policiers les gendarmes font bien leur
travail et que pour les quelques
personnes qui le font mal ils sont
contrôlés et quand il ya une faute il ya
une sanction après ce qu'il faut pas
oublier c'est que ceux qui sanctionnent
c'est le directeur général de la police
le directeur général de la gendarmerie
et ils l'ont dit et le président de la
république l'a rappelé il faut que ces
actions soient beaucoup plus rapide on
peut pas rester plusieurs mois avant que
le conseil de discipline se rassemblent
avant qu'une décision soit prise elle
peut être complexe cette décision il
peut y avoir des contre-pouvoirs
syndicaux il peut y avoir toute une
profession en attente de ces éléments il
faut que la sanction soit rapide quand
il ya une faute
je rappelle pour ceux qui nous
rejoignent et si vous n'avez pas pris
connaissance des principales mesures les
annonces des mamelles macron
multiplication par 2 de la présence sur
le terrain des policiers et gendarmes
budget du ministère augmenté d'un
milliard cinq
en 2022 dès l'année prochaine
simplification des procédures pénales
recours aux caméras donc cette instance
de contrôle dont on parle à l'instant je
reviens vers vous
sarah massoud
est ce que vous dites cadeau aux
policiers quand vous entendez ça un
milliard cinq d'euros de budget
supplémentaire pour le ministère l'année
prochaine
c'est vrai que vu le peu de cadeaux qui
est fait aux autres services publics on
pourrait dire que oui la police est
plutôt est plutôt bien logés après je
veux pas du tout mais estimé le fait
qu'il ya aussi des besoins les
conditions matérielles d'exercice des
policiers quand on rentre dans un
commissariat l'état des des bureaux
l'état du matériel informatique et à des
véhicules des cellules de garde à vue
sont extrêmement dégradées dans la très
grande majorité des des postes de police
et deux et de gendarmerie donc oui les
policiers ont les nécessités travailler
dans des conditions dignes après ce que
je conteste est ce que nous contestons
nouténé canam et le tract sûrs c'est que
c'est ces moyens soient là pour
augmenter le nombre d'effectifs de
police moi je voudrais qu'il soit là
pour véritablement faire une formation
idoine et de qualité on nous parle d'une
augmentation de 4 mois la formation
initiale et une augmentation également
de la formation continue mais quatre
mois c'est quasiment pas revenir aux
chiffres qui était celui au début du
quinquennat dans certains pays c'est nos
homologues européens ces déformations de
prix de 2 ans et là on nous parle que de
durs et or c'est pas que la durée dont
on doit parler dans le cadre des
formations des policiers on doit parler
aussi du contenu pourquoi est ce que le
contenu de cette formation elle est
principalement centrée sur la répression
principalement centrée sur les
techniques d'interpellation pourquoi est
ce qu'il n'ya pas plus de cours sur la
procédure pénale pourquoi est ce qu'il
n'ya pas plus de cours sur l'essence
sociale c'est tout ça qu'il faut
intégrer d'ailleurs au goût de la
sécurité il n'y avait pas d'université
erp à notre pôle up et sociologue qui
est invité aussi peut même très peu de
magistrats j'allais vous dire justement
un truc louis disciplinaire donc si les
moyens étaient donnés sur ça et c'est en
les policiers sont en demande de ceux de
ce type de formation parce que les
interactions sont beaucoup plus
compliquées dans la rue parce que comme
le disait le collègue policier
aujourd'hui de travailler policiers il
est aussi fait d'accompagnement sauf que
cet accompagnement il doit être affiné
c'est le travail de broderie là le
travail de police donc du coup ça
nécessite des moyens dans ses tuyaux là
et pas que parce que il faut du bleu sur
sur les trottoirs donc du coup je
m'interroge beaucoup sur la ventilation
des bouquets ouais je retiens ce que
vous dites sur la formation dans cette
intervention finalement cette impression
qu emmanuel macron est revenu au niveau
du début du quinquennat et que on
progresse pas quoi
photo s et on se renouvelle énormément
d'accord alors c'est de la broderie
peut-être mais c'est une broderie
extrêmement fine parce qu'on apprend
beaucoup beaucoup de choses à des jeunes
gardiens de la paix qui ont qui ont un
bac qui doivent en quelques mois
effectivement apprendre beaucoup alors
qu'est ce que la répression pas assez la
protection vous me dites quatre mois
c'est pas beaucoup mais c'est quand même
plus un tiers donc je connais pas
beaucoup de formations qui augmente en
quelques en quelques alors du coup alors
là on va passer de 12 mois à quatre mois
supplémentaires donc c'est beaucoup et
ils doivent apprendre beaucoup de choses
ils ont de la théorie effectivement
parce qu'à un niveau bac on doit
apprendre le droit et le droit pénal la
procédure pénale en france est complexe
on doit apprendre les techniques
d'intervention parce que c'est le
quotidien et du gardien de la paix qui
est dehors dans la rue et qui doit
assurer une sécurité en intervention
donc c'est normal après là où je suis
pas d'accord avec vous c'est qu'il ya
beaucoup beaucoup d'associations de
sociologues qui viennent dans les écoles
de police présentait le travail auprès
des victimes et ça c'est important mois
juste pour terminer ce que je voudrais
vous dire c'est que je suis fier de mon
ministère aujourd'hui je suis fier de
voir un ministère qui se bougent qui en
mouvement qui s'est donné les moyens de
rassembler autour de lui autour d'un
grand débat et on espère que les états
généraux de la justice se donneront
autant de résultats mais qui n'a pas eu
peur aussi de retransmettre l'ensemble
des débats sur les réseaux sociaux avec
on le sait sur twitter ou sur d'autres
réseaux des groupes qui sont pas
forcément d'accord avec nous on n'a pas
eu peur ce débat et on continue à
échanger sur ces questions parce qu'on
est persuadé qu'il ya un enjeu sociétal
et qu'on a besoin des citoyens qu'ils
soient derrière nous et qui pousse aussi
et c'est pour ça que le budget d'accord
on est content d'avoir 1 5 milliard
supplémentaire on souhaite à tous les
ministères en avoir autant et sachez
qu'on va bien l'utiliser dans le cadre
des réformes qui ont été annoncées
aujourd'hui j'ai honte durant votre
eyepet être sur la formation au soudan
dans ces débats on va essayer de creuser
donc là y'a tellement de sous thèmes
qu'on pourrait traiter mais là il nous
reste quelques minutes je voudrais vous
entendre sur la formation moi je
reviendrai au calendrier de tout ça
police de 2030 doublement du bleu dans
les rues
pour dans dix ans il ya une inertie
terrible dans ses systèmes
administratifs de formation de
recrutement quand on parle avec des
policiers et des syndicalistes ils nous
disent mais le recrutement pour
récupérer les emplois perdus sous
nicolas sarkozy il faut se souvenir de
nous ça hein le recrutement c'est dur et
du coup les notes des gens qu'on prend
pour avoir de gros effectifs recrutés
bas des fois c'est pas formidable la
formation c'est la même chose on est
passés donc de 12 mois à 8 mois on va
reprendre quatre mois
vous n'êtes pas d'accord sur les
chiffres et on revient et vous nous
dit-on cette passe de 12 à 16 si on
stage ou les périodes au sein de
l'écolier la scolarité et la formation
comptant les stars on était déjà là ya
deux théories supplémentaires ce qui est
quand même beaucoup donc on revient à ce
qui était fait en début de quinquennat
donc il ya quand même des allers retours
qui sont coûteux dans l'organisation et
c'est ça qui pose problème c'est que je
trouve que 1 le président de la
république dit je vous ai compris
essentiellement aux gendarmes et aux
policiers il n'était pas très loin de
lille donc c'est normal qu'on inspire de
du gaullisme et puis par ailleurs
irazein peu gratis parce que tout ça va
venir très tard donc sans doute c'est
très bien une quantité de mesures qui
sont annoncées mais comment on fait dans
le calendrier parlementaire on arrête de
bosser nous pour parler un peu
trivialement en février comment tout ça
va s'inscrire et en plus faut attendre
les états généraux de la justice pour
compléter le travail ça ne s'est pas
très engageant pour le président de
promettent de faire maintenant ce qu'il
n'a pas pu faire pendant le quinquennat
mais il a quand même donné pas mal aux
policiers pendant le quinquennat il ya
quelques chiffres 1 milliard 700
millions d'euros supplémentaires depuis
2010 est dix mille policiers et
gendarmes recrutés depuis 2018
et pour la revalorisation des carrières
et rémunération de 138 millions d'euros
david le voir sur la sur la formation
est ce que vous dites comme jérôme
durain finalement c'est un peu c'est la
valse quoi un pas en avant deux pas en
arrière et on est on vient on est venu
du début du quinquennat factuellement il
y avait une réduction de la scolarité
des gardiens de la paix il ya des
tensions politiques quand un quinquennat
décide de recruter 10 mais le gardien de
la paix si on n'augmente pas le nombre
d'écoles mais le seul moyen c'est de
baisser la scolarité endurer pour
recruter plus de gardiens de la paix moi
j'ai un avis assez tranché sur sur le
recrutement il faut stabiliser un
effectif est à rappeler une chose à ceux
qui nous regardent on a en policiers
gendarmes un très bon taux d'occupation
de policiers par rapport au nombre
d'habitants par rapport à l'europe on
est dans le premier tiers européens ce
qui est encore une fois vous allez faire
arrêter de recruter oui parce que le
mali le ministère de l'intérieur pour la
police nationale séance milliards le
budget annuel il y en a dix qui partent
pour la base salariale donc quand il
reste 1 pour investir plus on scrute -
il reste pour investir c'est pour ça que
les efforts financiers sont à saluer
mais je crois que le recrutement il faut
qu'on ait un chiffre de référence il
faut qu'on sache mieux répartir nos
policiers et nos gendarmes il faut
recruter des magistrats est là tuez
xsara massoud en est d'accord sur la
formation je la rejoins il faut
décloisonner les formations magistrats
policiers il ya des efforts à faire
gigantesque les magistrats vont quatre
mois voire les avocats en formation
initiale ne vont que quinze jours dans
les services de police faut inverser les
choses tout comme il faut envoyer des
policiers dans les tribunaux et au delà
chez les juges d'application des peines
pour savoir ce qui s'y passe et arrêter
les fantasmes le but c'est d'améliorer
la chaîne pénale si je dois retenir une
volonté politique du président ce matin
ces deux-là décloisonner de la faire
fonctionner mieux après on jugera par
les actes merci beaucoup merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat ici en
plateau et en duplex
évidemment les tice